(intro de vidéos)
Salut c'est Norman, aujourd'hui nouvelle vidéos de réponse au question c'est parti
tweet avec des moufles haha c'est très drôles  on sais tous ce que sa vas faire sa vas marqué n'importe quoi aller c'est parti (je suis actuellement en train de twitter avec des moufles! ) Bon voila c'est bon vous êtes content on a bien rigolé ou pas. Bah ouais j'ai des moufles avec des diamants qu'es ce que tu vas faire (Norman est en train de donner des coups de poings ) heu je vous fais la patate surprise haha excellent quand tu (coup de poings ) c'est marrant que tu dises sa parce que moi justement (coup de poings) La puissance
Montre nous comment tu te coiffe le matin (musique) Voila c'est bon je suis coiffé
(salut Norman je suis libanais) pardon c'est hyper raciste (salut Norman je suis libanais et je te suis de là bas et je parie) je suis en Cp je ne sais pas lire (que je ne passerai pas dans cette vidéos.) bah c'est faux tu y passe totalement et merci beaucoup de me suivre depuis le Liban c'est cool, sa fait toujours plaisir et internaute qui suis depuis l'étranger.
(Fait un canular téléphonique à un pote youtuber) hum hum, j'appelle Hugo (ouais allo) Hugo (heu oui) je suis un psychopathe qui veut te tuer( je suis a coté de toi enfaite là du coup sa ne marche pas quoi) ah ouais sa ne marche pas bien
Est ce que t'aimerais être une licorne unijambiste avec le tête de Gilbert Montagner, si oui, un dessin stp (Norman pense) euh euh euh non
(vas tu faire une chaine gaming) la réponse est non pas pour l'instant c'est pas prévue que je fasse de chaine gaming parquontre  sa ne pas empêché de faire récemment petite vidéos cool de gaming avec un vrai pro gamer vraiment hardcore c'est a dire mon père (musique)
aime tu les manga? De quel genre ?
alors je me suis mis assez tardivement au manga je me suis mis il y a un ans et franchement je kiff franchement les mangas que je kiff pour l'instant  dess note, l'attaque des titans, Tokyo roule et one piece que je viens de commencé mais vu qu'il y a plus de 700 épisodes je pense que j'aurais terminé quand j'aurais 45 ans
Ah! (j'ai un défi pour toi c'est de me follow avec @c_ludivinee) bah vas-y défi accepté oh mince j'ai raté le défi il était vraiment tros dur
(Quel est la taille de ton concombre) je trouve sa un peu abusé comme question bah vas-y moi je joue le jeu on me pose une question je vais répondre je le mesure c'est parti 22cm a je te jure je suis pas un mytho 22cm c'est la taille de mon concombre ahah excellent rien ne vaut la puissance d'un pu**** de concombre
(Demande a ton père, Jacky Thavaud) la meuf elle connaît toute ma life (de te raconter la plus grosse bêtise que tu as faite quand tu étais petit) papa c'est a toi (Alors Norman quand il a passé son bac au premier jour de la première épreuve il est arriver 30min en retard  donc il risqué de rater son bac alors il est aller voir le proviseur il a supplié de le faire entrer comme même dans l'épreuve il c'est excusé le proviseur ne voulais pas et puis finalement par compassion a accepté que Norman exceptionnellement intégré l'épreuve et le lendemain 2éme épreuve Norman est arriver 30 min en retard)
hum bah quoi finalement j'ai comme même eu mon bac avec mention retard
(Est ce que tu peux mettre une photo de moi dans ta vidéos stp p s je m'appelle Thomas Zittoun merci) je ne peut pas ne pas mettre la photos de se mec c'est a dire qu'il a 12ans mais il est déjà dans la vie active cette photos c'est sa photos pour sa campagne électoral (musique)
(Fais nous ton interprétation de JCDV) arrêté les claquements merde je ne suis pas venue en temps que moviestar  je suis venue en temps de Jean-Claude Jean-Claude c'est Jean-Claude vendame c'est mon prénom ta compris je suis venue parlé avec le cœur et quand je dit avec le cœur c'est aussi avec ma bouches parce que je ne parle pas avec la bouche sa veut dire que je suis muet et si je suis muet je ne suis plus une movie star ouais j'adore la vie ah moins d'être une movie star qui tourne  dans la famille bélier t'a compris je suis venue parler cœur et aussi avec mes oreilles avec mes yeux mes tetons et mes couilles hum t'a compris et c'est sa
la vie mon frère bon on fait kick j'adore la vie
(Comment était ton public a Rennes) comme sa
(Sinon combien de temps va durer ta tournée? Ton spectacle étais super cool) je joue que a Paris a partir du 15 octobre 2015 jusqu'à noël et si vous voulais me voir en dehors de paris je reprendrai ma tournée a partir de 2016 voila les places sont déjà dispo
(Que pense tu des Pokémons?) bah ecoute je joue a Pokémon depuis que je suis tout petit j'ai joué a quasiment toute les cartouches mais je me dit vu qu'il y a plein d'adultes qui joues a Pokémon pourquoi il ne ferait pas des cartouches spécial adultes tu vois avec des Pokémons un peu plus hardcore limasperme, cocainozebre, pédophélin, hitlerisson, porcépute , toxicanard, tentacouilles ,travéstigre , antisemouette, tortue violence conjugale
(Un nom pour ta communauté) la communauté de l'anneau alors c'est une bonne question c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas la prétention de pouvoir donner un nom au gens qui me regarde alors je vous propose un petit truc peut être pouvait suggérer des proposition de nom en terme et puis mettez vous des pouces les un les autres et peut-être il y a une proposition qui en sortira du lots allez y proposez vous des noms de communauté on va se marrer soyons foufous on se lâche un peu. Merci d'avoir regarder ma vidéos continué a vous abonné un max et je vous dit a bientôt en vidéo ou dans la vrai vie
au fait les meufs de twitter bah je vous follow avec plaisir (OUTRO de vidéos)
sous titres fait par eythan roncier